Can I have that?
Hey! Alright. Fine then?
Whoa
Okay
What the hell? Hi.
Hey! Oh, it was a mimic! Oh, that's what's that was. Oh!
I just wasted two goddamn shotgun shells okay. Hello, everybody my name is Markiplier and Welcome back to uh...
Welcome back to Prey, we're off to a bad start because I didn't even realize that Mimic. Why did I even think?
It was a box that frickin moved.
Why didn't it process in my brain that that could have possibly been a mimic?
Because I am dumb and that's why but I think I got everything that I need from over here
So I'm just gonna make one last glance around, ooh what's up there? Hello, can I climb up you?
I think I can, hang on, I've never been able to ooh hi.
Hello science operator. What are you doing up there? I'll be right with you in just a second Imma try this, huh?
Well, yea, sure do that movement.
Yes, that is me. I am Dr. Yu, ah
That guy running for his life was way better than this than I was well
Let's see if I got a little bit of skill here, NOO
Oh, yeah, that looks good
Ha-uh-ha ha ha hu-ha
Whoa, hey, whoa didn't expect that all right hang on you go real slow. You go real slow
Gonna bash ya in your goddamn head. Blap!
Oh no you're out cold. Blap. Blap. Blap. Bla-Oh whoa hey. NO you don't!
Ha okay. Got those guys handled pretty good. I'll take that.
And I'll take that and I need...
So many more shotgun shells but thankfully crafting them up produces a lot of shotgun shells I don't know how I?
All right, yeah, I'll be right with you. Hey!
Hey, you Freaking douche bag
Whoa, where you at, where you at oh, you got me good blap so we got that escape Pod key well that seems important
I don't even remember needing an escape Pod
All right, I'll be with you in just one second I
Yes! I Got the airlock for Psychotronics open which means that I can go out side if I so choose.
Probably encounter those horrible monstrosities outside that wanted to  kill me. Oh, so dead. Which was never a fun time
Hello science operator. You've got a nice voice. Can you come over here? Hey? I'm calling you ... sciency!
Science Operator come back please, ohhh
Apparently I found my way Labs B and, ooh, there's goodies in there
Can I just scamper in here, see, I didn't read with that note said, 'Not a Mimic'
Uh-huh one of these is going to be a lie. No that's for sure.,all right fine then not a mimic
Ohh, something up there is a Mimic though
Hey
No, no, no,no, no, no, bleb, bleb, blebulub aha. I saw that, you can't hide from me.
What the hell?
I just saw it!
Oh hi, hello there. I'm gonna scan you. Give me a little bit of oh yeah
Keep dancing for me baby, keep dancing. Scan complete.
Uh. Mimic Matter. OH!
Mimic Matter right
Uh-Huh Sure it is blap blappity blap oh
Alright. Got that guy. Where's that other mimic go?
Oh, holy shit, I glued him about, uh, meant to get him, meant to scan him, but I didn't get it
Sure I'll get plenty of other opportunities. Hhoever was in here was
paranoid.
Well, I mean for good reason if everything around you could possibly be a mimic then there's no reason not to be paranoid
It's the only thing that's gonna keep you alive after a while
And there there are a lot of notes here
I'm not gonna bother to collect them all 'cause that would just be a waste of my time and total bullshit. Ohh, Hello. Ohh!
Another Whiteboard?!
Whoa? Oooohhhh
What is that?
What is all that? I don't know but I'm gonna take this
*Reading*
Well, that's bizarre
I don't know what that means because that's beyond my own idea
*Reading the whiteboard*
Oh, this is hypothesis!
*Continues to read the whiteboard*
Well that seems like the least likely considering how much energy that would probably take to maintain a wormhole
But okay, sure let's go with that hypothesis
Hmm, what else they got here? Uh
Colorful! Now what's with the yellow colors? Because I've only seen blue electricity so far and also, what's with this weird, hi
No.
Okay
Okay.
Like old times! Maybe before you trapped me in a constant loop of my own life. My own personal Groundhog Day.
*Reads Email*
Oh? Is there a mimic in there? Oohh, OOHH
Alrighty then
Well, we tried that and that didn't seem to do anything because I don't think there were any mimics in there
But I blew it up real nice
Whoo. Heeey. Ooohhh
Let's try this. Oh.
Blurb.
I guess it's too late didn't that goof it up already, alright fine. Then I'm moving on
What's that? Typhon Lure? I don't know if I want a ehhhhhhh
I don't know why
Why this is necessary.
*Reads*
Well, okay?
I guess the idea was that they wanted to study these things more, oh my God, oh
It is beautiful
Just not hundred percent sure why?
Blep, blep. Can I scan you guys? What is this? It's like some sort of typhon plant
But I guess. you know. if they are even an organism. if they even have cells is a good question I guess
Weird, alright I'll take these Sci-Fi boats and just be on my way. Oh
Okay, well maybe I shouldn't just, you know, press random buttons. What are you doing? What are you doing there squiggly-sqoo?
Oh, look at you with your long swag legs
Alright. *Reads*
Oh, and that's what it's doing.
Oh, that was the lure
Okay, well now I get to kill that thing, but still that's pretty cool. Ohh, more neuroma. Thank you. Yes
Maybe I could actually use them the mimic technique
I know, I know it said that if I use too many of them, I'm gonna lose myself
but I have a funny feeling I'm already lost to begin with
Whoah, weird
Alright anyway. Yadadi. I don't think I can go in there anyway. I don't think I'd want to, hang on
What's this? Hello? 'Not a Mimic'
Yes, this whiteboard is definitely not a mimic, good job. You figured out the mystery. Blepiddyblep. Hello, oh
God damnit, right infront of my goddamn face
You frickin' asshole. What the fuck?
Blep, blep, blep
Alright, get out of here. Where'd you l-ooh
I see...
You're gonna try to get away from me, huh?
Alrighty, then. This guy's got a GLOO gun?
Sounds like I need more of the GLOO guns, but, oh no, he was writing all the nada Mimic notes
Oh, Jeez
Oh, Oh-oh
I didn't mean to do that
I thought it was broken, so I didn't even know what the point of hacking it would be, but here I go anyway, I suppose
Get down there
Shubbidy, shubbidy, shubbidy. Oh God, oh God, oh God, oh God, ohh X
Yay I hacked it! I don't know why. I  meant to listen - lemme listen to that again
Ahh God damn it.
Ahh God damn it! AAHH! What the hell? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey
None of that. Blep and blep, okay, let me read this first
I also realized I didn't read the emails in the other room *reads*
Interesting, let me read these first though
*Reads*
Sorry
*Reads another mail*
Are you talking about his brain?
You're gonna scoop out his brain, is that what I'm hearing here?
You're gonna, you're going to gladly
Scoop out his brain, because that's exactly what you should be doing about that. Also guts is, what? Oh, guts is over there
But there was another terminal over here that had emails I think
And I get distracted by that. *Reads*
Oh boy, alright that's what they were talking about with the different versions of what could happen *reads*
*Still reading*
Well that's actually fascinating because, yeah, somebody could just waltz in if everybody had neuro mods installed
And then someone got introduced and then a week later he disappeared in everyone's Neuro module were removed then he would just be gone
right?
What's the point of a back entrance into there? I don't even need it, and it's all just looping back and forth, alright
What else do- Oh, I need to listen to this
Yeah
Okay, nevermind then I guess we're not going to do that
Alright, we're just gonna do this over and I'm gonna stand right here listen to this bitch
Okay, that's it. Allight, then that's all we're gonna get out of that. Thank you. That was very helpful
You're really appreciated. Is there a way into this place
Or is it all just locked off? This seems pretty locked off cognitive sciences
I'm gonna go over the other side, see what we can find over there
Man the mystery of like what's going on, because these guys have been studying these mimics for a long time now, right? They
They had to have it, I mean-
Hi
Hi, hey, hey, hey, hey none of that, none of that, none of that, where are you?
Which one are you? Which object in here are you? Why are all these broken? Why don't I have Repair II?
Okay, I know the piece of the space station blew up
I forgot that we were in space and probably an imminent danger of death
and vacuum
Man, but they have typhon organs just lying around here. It's no wonder that any of them like got out in the first place
They just have everything out in the open. I mean if these things are as infectious as I think they might be, which seems to be the case, considering that like
These guys came in on an asteroid just one of them and yet they keep duplicating and when you shove them in your eyeball it
Probably is gonna be bad and people are probably gonna die from it. AHHH, bitch. Oh fuck
Well, I'm gonna throw a grenade in there. Don't know which one this is, but there we go
I don't think that was the one I wanted, bop
How about that? *weird ass throwing noise Mark does all the time- for real what the hell should I put as subtitles lmao*
Whoa, that got some of them good. I'll take that. Thank you very much
I don't think I have too many of those but I know
There's one more you assholes in here. I don't know where you went
I want to find you. Alright, fine then. He's gonna be hiding like a little blaster
hello
Okay, well that's not what I wanted
Apparently real good because this ain't working right damn it
Where's my goddamn? No not that one [I] dropped a couple of nightlight there
We go phantoms away put sticky notes on every goddamn thing. I'm sure is a mimic you
Good this safe inside the armory [this] [costume] [in] [Macbeth] slipped in but that's it. [I] got everything still tight
What's our plan?
wait for rescue
You know if we make it?
Alex is just going to pull our mods. You want to remember this shit?
[I] think we could get out through the guts work our way up to the Arboretum
Okay, say the word
Yeah, something tells me that wasn't too good of an idea because I don't think it worked out for them and also what's going on?
over there
like they must have encountered something because I don't think that particular video can end very well uh
All righty then
But anyway
There's still, there's still a dude in here somewhere for example
Conducting a meta-analysis of over 2000 ganzfeld valve trials wherein participants are subjected to mild sensory deprivation in order to test for telepathy
Reveals a hit rate of 39% these results are statistically significant meaning that the success rate is above
What could be explained by chance alone? There's no denying it something spooky is going on [ah]?
so people are getting all sorts of
Spooked here. I need to find my way [through] here
Oh such intense hacking music going on in here. Too bad I dont need it I'm too much of a pro anyway. Ah bloop done
Record time and what have we got here. the volunteer transtar sends us our irredeemable sociopath sentenced to die for their crimes
We are neither judge nor jury. We only enable their already ordained destruction to the benefit of all humanity
Read the file on 13 if you need assurance. It's unlocked in the extraction [lab]
I managed to lock the my morgue Keycard in the morgue tell strip thinks. I'm an imbecile as it is have any ideas
Nope. I ain't got nothing to help you because you're probably dead
Let me get the rest of this find out where that goddamn mimick is. Ha nope not that one you
[hey] was you ah I thought I would be shooting you and it didn't work out that way [alright]. Where you going?
Oh, I see you oh, I see you okay. No no no no
I'm not blah blah blah stay there getting the rest of this other Mimic. Thank you. That's what I needed mimic matter number, two
Let me just get this guy
Okay, reload please need to reload faster aiiehh not today
your doneso
Where did you go? You're all the way over there? [oh], it's [another] phantom, okay?
I don't need to go chase after that guy [just] yet. I need to keep going forward. Where are my-here we go
Atleast i've unlocked just about everything over here. Yeah, come back for that guy later. Hi-yah
What the fucking hell!
Okay, I'm going to blap you and I'm going to blap you
blam
And blap. Ok i think I've got him. that was good enough, man. That was someone who was that?
Also, this god i need more, i need more, so I just used a key lee when the helo. [oh], im probaly gonna need it
I'm gonna need it. I'm Gonna need it
not today
Get gooped. Come on get gooped! How much goop do you need?! So much goop on you!
Yeah
There we go
Whoa that guy had a lot of stuff all right, so we got a medical officer over here
That I can definitely use because I'm dying very currently yes, please. Thank you. Heal me
Oh, it's because I need [to] learn are you here for an appointment [nice] housing special injuries nothing a portable medical kit can handle yeah
[no], no, I get to complete a patient questionnaire your feedback will be invaluable all right. Thank you. All right
Have a good day [all] right, so I think I got everything that I needed over here
So I need to find that escape pod. oohhh it's gonna hurt me! whoa not today. Oh, yeah
You come from where are these these freaking phantoms are coming out of the wall
Stagger you back. I'm just gonna hit ya while you're down. Oh
whoa, whoa
execution-style
Holy shit
Alrighty then I guess that's cool. All right
I'm gonna go in here, [and] I'm going to render all my bullshit into broken pieces
I don't think I need to go outside into space just yet, and I'm [gonna] remember to do that up
Real good like [okay]
I'ma bop my boo-boos in there
And then we're just going there and slap them into recyclables and see if I can craft up another bit of Google
Sure, buddy boo boo boo boo boo, okay. What else we got here?
We need to make I'm always about more shotgun shells like that's just wait
It's just neuromod! Oh i saw a neuromod whoa [I] can make a neuromod. Oh
Hell yeah, oh hell
Yeah, oh hell
Yeah, oh my God. I need so much more [material] screw making bullets or anything like that
I need to make neuromods because now I should be able to
Get something of this now. I know I shouldn't go too. Deep into this but [you] know
I'm just too tempted deals up to 50 damage. Oh that sounds too cool. I want to do that one
Yeah, let's do it. Oh hell. [yeah], and then I'm gonna get the mimic because that's just something cool
I don't know how to do that, but i'm gonna try it
I'm turning into an alien everybody. I'm turning into a frick frack an Alien who?
psionic aptitude
Many other goodies than I need oh, that's always good
I could get more health but I could also get salvage which allows me to get more spare parts
But do I really need [that] many
Oooh those, ooh those look pretty good. Ah those look pretty good
You know what might as well if I'm gonna be used more of these abilities. I always want more psychic
[I'm] [just] [I] [uh] [oh] God
Maybe it was a bad idea
don't know them do this to you [ah]
oh
Do you remember?
The first time you said it was like. You are outside yourself like climate self-invented [me]
Waiting for you to decide
You move my chair without touching it
chills
possibilities ah
Okay, as I believe now
Our mission is to live all humanity in the same way
Okay, yeah
sure
that's probably a good idea psi targeting some powers are triggered instantly by
Pressing mouse to some powers are targeted to stop time and enter psi targeting mode press an old mouse to use mouse to aim release
Mouse to to execute power on the targeted location or press [f] to cancel powers can be equipped from the favorites wheel
there's probably like some purity way to
Finish the game where you don't need any of these mods to be able to do that. [well]. What's the fun in that?
Holy shit
Why is that?
That's the girl
[I] don't know what I did
Holy shit, okay, that's talking light things on fire
Well, that's handy Dandy I
Can't dude Dandy Dandy [alright] what I need to do is I need to get over to goods
No
[labs] ian have [you] so many labs? Hello, sorry?
Yes, well
[oh], I feel so much more alert. Thank you very much. Did I just go in a circle?
I feel like I just went in a big-ass circle
Well, I don't all good good, but that seems like something can I climb out there?
Hole buddy, Bobby, okay, what about this?
Yeah, that's probably good enough. Hello. Oh, oh, oh
Okay, all right there. We go where am I now why this where I was?
I'm just [wearing] one word this doesn't help me at all, but I will use my
Will use some super pair kits because why not I've got them why not?
Now that'll be [good] [for] now. I don't know if I need a sale nice to see you, okay, hi
Thank you. You have a good day now
Being all weird and whatnot I'm Gonna go down here
I'm gonna see about this escape Pod key because guts didn't seem to do nothing for me. No wait wait
[I] wasn't even at guts yet. That's right. [okay]. I know where I'm going [I] think it
All right, what do we got here?
[uh-Huh]?
Yeah, looks like you're gonna have more time
Probably allowing them to build all this shit in the middle of your space station is what killed all the people on it
I'm just gonna throw [that] out there and also the fact that people seem to be turning into all these [Thai] [phones] is bad
Just began throwing that out there, okay now. [I] know where I need to go
I just went in the big circle that it was already where I was [posed] [to] be
Okay
How good bullets in the freaking toolbox everybody's favorite pool [than] bullets?
Now [we'll] get here. Come on suppressor man, because live exams morgue. Oh, that's oh
Ah it seems bad, oh
[goddamnit] here the signs is here. We're in the middle of something when they died
Access to the gut is closed off during experiments security protocol
Okay to finish what they started why do I need to finish what they started even?
70s the first research teams tried to communicate with the time all has proved impossible
Their cerebral structures are highly developed and intentional but somehow
unapproachable
They have no speech of their own no language
They don't seem to even see us
Not like way see ourselves. I mean
I'm generalizing when I say us of course. I'm not a person not like you
Okay, all right, then well way to be self-aware about yourself in progress local lockdown in a clock until procedure terminate oh
Okay, I wanna do I'm gonna Deploy the null wave oh
Don't know why that startled me. Hey. How are you doing? All right? I'm gonna
Take this from you. We have a good day. I'm good nana
Good day, no, I'm not open this up and try to see what's in there because I do not know
Open as me. Oh that's not what I wanted to open oh
[maybe] it is. Maybe it is what I window
oh
Yeah
Or no, well, I got that
All right, I don't know if it's gonna do anything to me come on. [oh]
Boy, oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Okay? Let me see if blue affects it, but I have a funny feeling it
Okay, let me try to smack him. That's a good idea get that that's it. Oh. God. Oh, God. Oh boy
Let me get this back up and pull it
glued
That's not good so I can disable my weapon somehow
Just a a comfortable distance away
Bam
Matt back a hole that seems to be able to do like [a] one-two punch to him that seemed to do a one-two [punch] for
Me as well. That's okay got [my] glue
Ready to goo
tap-tap
There we go. [just] [being] near that thing supposedly does [be] [damaged]. Oh, baby
[better] this human features
The - kill us without hesitation, but it's not because the evil is because they can't do otherwise
Huh, no, what we discovered
the Greater of Hodgman's
All their wonderful abilities, there's one thing we can do that. They can't
Empathize with the suffering of [another] living creature
Okay, oh, hi. [what's] [gone] there? Can I scan you apparently well? Thank you for being there?
[I] just repaired my suit like a singers, but maybe I would have needed it for this one
Alright good got that, okay, Kenny. [oh], your integrity is awfully good
[me] like I knew you would thank you robot buddy, alright. Fine, man. Carry on
So what is the weaver the weaver seems to be the thing that transforms?
Like at least human anatomy into something else. I mean even if its corpse that's super weird. It's able to turn corpses
Into whatever the hell. That was okay. Lou Danny. Whoa that's also useful
combat useful, but relatively useful
I'll take it [all] right, so I got both of these I should be a bit more stealthy about my life
But you [know] may I keep
Blasting forward at the speed of light into everything I see let's get reload speed up on that bad boy
And let's get ammo capacity up on that bad boy. I need to get rid of this - I
Wish I could dismantle that right on cue oh
Is that an ability the ability to dismantle things right on cue oh?
if that is oh, oh
Oh, that's a V oh that's handy if I needed that, but I don't think that applies to absolutely everything
All right, I think that's just for the various things that would normally be trying to keep oh, oh
Okay, [alright]. I'll go down here, but I'm not gonna be happy [about] it
I'm in the fork hey, hey come on now. I know what you is. I saw that
I'll never mind. I guess I didn't see anything. [I] guess I'm just a
All right, well we got mimics in here all right tossing equip [psychos] go prior to Viewing but why?
Why would you need a psycho scope before you view something?
Why would you need [that] filter? I mean obviously they have some sort of psychic influence. There's a reason
Why that guy was mind controlled but why they said they had no language of their own and yet somehow
They're able to like influence us. They're able to pull
Well, that's the deterrent
Party then good great. I'm glad I did that. They're able to just do that
I don't know how that works also. How do I [ooh]?
How do I do that I?
Wanna I wanna do that I don't know how
What?
What oh?
That's cool. Okay. Hi there hi that's going blap. [oh]
Wait come back wake where are you going? Wait? Where you going? Come on when it's kids limit you oh, no, you're jealous
More specimens [ago], and I thought I got enough as it were hi, not salmon
I mimics into a mimic Mimic a minimum in the maker. [I'm] Gonna get you oh
Yeah
[they] seem to die well enough and know like by themselves, so they don't seem to be too
incredibly resilient I'm indisposed Demian [Kelce] trip wants to discuss some urgent matter the science operator lets itself in the morgue by
[half-hour] on the dot every day shadow it and slip in
Remember, how funny, I found alvin Broyles movies up until I had [the] second comment tutorial combinatorics
Neuro Mod installed now they can't even elicit a chuckle. I'm not imagining this [m] I did
I enjoy them right
[Haley] isn't happy about it ever since she's scrutinized my every move how much hot sauce I use where I put my [shoes] before bed
Shit even my handwriting you'd say you're still the same person you [were] before your mods with it
Would you I don't know I don't know how in depth these mods are
Do they actually?
Rewire your brain only to the way your brain is already wired, or did they rewire it to a template?
Into what another person already is [hey]
There was no need [for] that. Did you somehow blow you?
All right, man. [I] don't [know] what the hell just happened, but something happened
More [near] real [Nazia] city. I'm going to get fayed. I'm going to be dead indeed unless I cannot to open this
Bullshit, so oh wait the science operator every half an hour Lisa hi, hi come on
You got [to] be goofy?
Oh, no, your dad
Okay, but that means [ooh] hey, how's it going there? How you doing?
You don't look good, but I'm gonna assume. You're all right. Whoo. Hey, maybe I should
[slap] you ha oh come on
[brigance] [creamy] screamer, sit over there. Why don't you take your wines and go somewhere else?
Are you much more appreciated than where I am?
Hello. Thank you good thing
I got all this bio waste cuz I sure want to do carry giant bags a fetid shit all over the place
That's my dream
Okay, so apparently the science operator goes into that room
But I have no idea [when] that's gonna be and I'm not just going to wait around for that even though oh my God
Oh my God
These poor people there's so many dead bodies. [oh] my God. There's so many dead bodies. [oh]
alrighty then
Alright
Cool cool cool cool [alright], so anyway you see this again
Okay, so it said something about Shadowing a science
Operator but I don't think there's a science operator in this area
I'm not on represent sure about that, but also I also just realized I need to do
this optional mission
Somewhere in here in Alex's private Escape Pod. I need to find
The key to his escape Pod in the neuro mod division which means I would [have] to go back to the Lobby which I'm totally
fine with doing
I just need to make sure that going to gus isn't going to absolutely devastate my progress or not devastate my progress
But making sure that it can't progress further anymore, which isn't necessarily a bad thing. I'm not saying it is
I'm just saying I better be thorough about this hey science operator
Maybe I should shed
And you want to you want to go over there? I'm gonna go into the I want to go into the morgue the
[morgue]
Can I ride you? Oh you having a good time there? Sorry don't buck me off
[so] I'm going to go look for this escape Pod
Be right back when I get them
Where is this?
[weight] this [is]
[weight] this is back to the beginning
This back to the beginning of the game
Where I first came out of why would alex use or at least the key to his escape Pod be over here?
Curious and curiouser I'll be back when I find more answers
What oh my God? It's been up here this whole time
Sorry Morgan, not sure how you [managed] this, but I can't love you. Have this key card trust me. You'd regret it what?
Why do I have?
disrupter stun gun hell, yeah
Your office isn't safe. [what] does that mean? I got a [chipset], but for what purpose
I'm so confused
Why did I come back here? Why?
I wanted to [follow] up on my request to view one of the volunteer abdication contracts
You're supposed to be off today
[I] had some free [time] so I thought I already told you the [cases] are sealed documents
My hands are tied, but if there's some allowance for the researchers oh
my God the one pushing the button I
Understand I really [do]
I think done is perfectly
There are no loss, and you're tired. [it's] affecting your judgment [now]. I'm all waiting it for a while, but not
[good] look you might be late for a meeting with Alex
Not too late to flush it all out an airlock. You know, okay? Are you having second thoughts? No way? I'm it's [just]
Not the one incriminated
No, have the answers for me either way. I'm trying not to think possible
Did you pick [arrangement] metals on board? It's Gonna bring me food. I don't need the details
[oh], I
Put everything in a package to label mementos the packages in my cabin. It's got to go every media outlet imaginable
Morgan it's that operator with an earlier defective model or something worse?
Alex the tyson they're all working against you drive [some]
Trust the video you move we're worried the army keys and Destroy talos watch
You might need this 374
[640] late
[in] seven [general] [interests] [oh] yeah, I did. Why are you so curious about it? Hi, okay? Where'd you go?
All right, bye. Van you skinner off into the darkness the [taiping] have already demonstrated an ability to Distort technology
including operator programming
Storage the more you see of Talos 1 the more you'll understand why you made the decision to destroy everything if it's not obvious already
Yeah, I understand if you feel
Uncertain you goddamn right?
I'll do everything in my power to help you and keep you safe. Yeah, sure you will okay storage Morgan
We need your arming key, okay? I'll contact you again later. Thanks, January
Did you blow up December earlier defective model? I don't like the Sanatana, and I don't like January
I didn't see that there was something up here. Let me try to go up here before I continue back
[lower] [I] oh, whoa, whoa hey hey, hey, I'm [up] here now
Anybody want a tussle with the muscle the mark of all Zoltan coming at you?
[Shambo] Ski Sam lamb, [oh] [amen]. Thank you
I'm tired
But there we go
That really take my time with that last hit it was quite a wallop that I was gonna lay down on you
I just needed really burying about it. Oh, what is up here?
This is a day of exploration
apparently
Volunteering testing. Oh something tells me that volunteering testing isn't going to be too fun
Someone tells me it's a horrible place where people go to the quote-unquote volunteers are these the same [people] that can like convicted to test
Then we're convicted to death they're convicted to be death to be [death] [doubt] they're going to die they were convicted to be desc
Fifty you know what I mean, okay? Hello
[why] [am] [I] over here? [oh]?
Hi, Manny Miki
[slooshy] all right yep, your spade is sealed buddy. [I] got a critical apparently whoa
Where am I what is this mate into white turn? [who's] doing chest what nerd was doing [chess] over here? Oh?
Hello, buddy
These guys you guys aren't able to see me very good. We got a big guy over there
Let's see about dealing with them. Oh yeah. [see] [me] yet. Hopefully that means I can find some sort of explosive canisters before
I'm able to tussle with him
All right
Give me what you got oh
Never mind. I [don't] have enough okay, so I need to find a salvage kid eventually but oh, yes
Please and we'll take [that] with great appreciation
So the only problem here is that all these stupid mimic tumors are taking up all my inventory space, but maybe with these
Neuromas I should be able to make another
inventory storage one
Yeah, I
Can okay so if I get that then I should be okay? Yes, all right now
Let me organize this bad boy, and let me pick up this shit that I need
On the easiest [dude] all right, so we got that let me pick [up] this shit. [I] don't check their shelves enough
That's just something that doesn't register in my brain
that
By always can I get the bio ace?
And get the bio ace why can't I get the bio [is] not that I want to put more shit [in] sediment?
One ever take what I can get we're not
Gonna Pop [that] guy out because I know I'm gonna be in soon
I'm almost got a glue [dammit]
[alright] you want to go Mano-A-Mano. How come on? Oh any mono with you? Huh? Yeah yeah, yeah yeah, yeah, yeah?
Yeah, oh, no, you don't get close [to] me. What could you do? What did you do?
What can you do you can get dead? That's what you can do take some of value a little mastered all right?
What do we got here? Oh?
These are some of the volunteers for weaver testing to be we've woven into something horrible's [bin'] hello
Can you heal me now that I really need it, but any little bit will help diagnosing
[initial] injuries nothing [a] portable medical kit couldn't handle try relax [good] as new
You can fill out a service questionnaire at the front desk [all] right, whatever. I'm Gonna heal anyway. Give him a food
Whoa [alright] then why did we need to dramatic music cues I?
Think that was entirely linzer
Anything else I can get here
no, I
Think I [just] went in a circle, so there's another path of a cure emile. Why why so many volunteers why so many?
Underhanded Shady ways of going about [it]. I didn't do that ah get blasted in the next century by ouch
Got more shotgun shells [too]. So wasn't a waste. It was not a waste. Okay. I'm not going what does this lead to?
[more] horror hell holes. I'm gonna guess more horror hell holes
Seems to be a majority here. Thanks for the Dorama Joshua
Again, I'm running into the situation with her so many corpses
endless Corpses everywhere
White noise we've also we also talked about that
White noise makes it sound like they're (uh) the untouchables in the in the warhammer 40k universe
You know what I'm saying big bang Candy burns circuit or nothing good
here
Nah, no information, whatever the hell that is over there
I
Mean it's just a kind of like you know cliche
corporate espionage type bullshit like Shady Shadow corporations testing on the the myriad of people who are just
subjected to death
Wait, no, I'm all the way back in [our] indeed time to get over here. [oh], I want to go to there
Can I go [over] there?
Who can I go to there?
I thought that was the thing that I was haven't I been there before how do I get in there?
There's got to be a way to get in there right? [oh], I want to go in there
I think maybe around nah that wouldn't leave me there. I'll get in there
Gotta be away. I'll be right back. Oh, that's right. It goes through that door. I can't go there
Ha ha ha welcome volunteers yay
Oh boy
It's not a good happy place happy place filled [with] sunshine. Oh
Hi, okay. I don't think I can move these I don't think I can squeeze in there
Nah no hi. Yeah, nope
Gotta get some [hey] fuck you. No, no, you know what I ain't gonna even bother with you
You just run off and be stupid somewhere else
I'm Gonna go risk death along here
Fine back on track because apparently Alex used keys in there
But I did get the code to it before January blue of December
And I think December was trying to help me out, and I don't know why December and January we're different [people]
And I don't know why January is trying to cover up for the death of December by saying it was a [defective] older-Model
I mean if there was anything that painted January's a bit of a shady object
Then that would definitely be the one of them because I don't trust
You you're late. [I'm] out of here, baby. [I] am out of here, and I don't think there's Gonna be the final frontier
So I think I should be okay
Also, I have a jet pack. Which is why I'm able to survive these jumps now. How the do be given your name. Yeah
Wait, where do you go [psychic] products? Hell? Yeah?
Let's go for it. Shoot me
Okay, so I'm wondering if I have just enough flu oh
Whoa, whoa, what the fucking fuck oh?
Hell, do you think you are?
[here] you better back off of me. You better back off of me. You don't know what I'm Gonna do to you
You know what? I'm gonna do hey hey hey. I mean hey. I'm sorry trying to get the mimics too many Mimics [Randy]
Thank you. Oh very nice. Thank you very much for that. I'm not gonna get dressed a different shit
Trudy you [know] why I didn't [just] let them all burn look last one yeah
Slap hello, there's neural mods in there. [I] want them. Can you give them to me? [oh]?
Yeah
Oh, okay. Where are my knitting cereal? [hi]? How are you? Hi homo Sapiens?
All right, you seem like a hundred percent human Saamana trust you
They're about to be a choice here. Well you need guns
Ammo, I sold [in] size pots. Go to that armory punch in the code
You get me out of here. I'll let you have it
Okay, that seems like a fair trade Aaron Aaron Ingram
Okay, those other fellows [were] russian. I speak a little but as you can tell I ain't from there
Uh-huh as you might've guessed Amata
You know I used to be a reverend
Training [ward] in place
well
I got locked up uh-huh behold the wicked man conceives evil is pregnant with mischief and gives birth [to] live okay
What are you trying to prove here anybody? You know no, it doesn't actually [I]?
Don't know okay volunteer says subject criminal record [for] [y'all] reverse proof reviewing alright male human trafficking kidnapping
Solicitation of a minor distribution of controlled substances fraudulent impersonation well he seems like a bad guy
please ranked Mimic A
Rap sheet huh? Yeah I sure am I'm telling you. [oh], my mom is great
That is a stack of lies meant to make pushing that button easier on you. What button okay fine, listen, I?
Want to be honest some of it probably is true
I've done some wrong in my days. [uh-uh] this ain't right now
Come on. Y'all got to let me out of here, okay?
Well, I don't [think] I'm exactly an executioner here something those kids I
Was just getting them out of a bad spot. Can you just stop talking your new criminals?
[I] didn't like how chipper with their pile of rubles
They got the call something deep in the government
Got me shipped off to the gulag. Can you just that's how I ended up here. Can you just stop while you're ahead okay?
I was debating letting you out
All right fine. You know what I don't think I can do
Extract Mimic what does it even mean does it mean extract Mimic now. God [dammit] let me out
oh ho, ho
Methinks the mimics be going cray cray in there, whoa
Hey, ha they're fighting they wanting to get out real bad
[whoo] that is [a] lot of material [on] a moving cart?
That's so weird
I
Guess they get impatient after a while
All right, you know what I'm going to open this door not because I like you
[oh]
Because you're useful to me
Stab me in the back I dare you using the extraction
Workstation complete the following steps in the listed order while a volunteer test subjects is present in the extraction chamber
Extract Mimic from containment release Mimic into material extraction chamber when multiplication process is complete extract exotic material
Process material and collect from dispenser tray immediately transport remains to the morgue so I can kill them for more exotic material
But what does that make me that makes me a terrible shitty person, so I'm going over the door. It doesn't make any sense
There you go
You're free [now]. I think I'm talking about some human decency [friend]. Uh-huh
Well hello
What are you gonna do? Are you gonna run? [oh], where are you going? [hey]? Where [are] you going?
You said you'd get me into the goddamn room gone now
Gone now, where's gone? Where you going?
Aaron you're the one person who showed me any real kindness, and you can believe I won't forget it
Well don't forget if I still want that okay eight seven one four
Okay, thank you listen. You running the other fellas wearing a green jumpsuit
Watch your ass
Are they in all decent human beings like me?
I've seen one of the other volunteers come through here a big guy
Bastard wouldn't let me out now. I'm glad he didn't
Watched him bash some poor suckers head in with a wrench kept going on and on about black eggs and Whatnot real disturb
alrighty then
So whatever you say [Aaron] you carry on being a decent individual with a ha just lay [low] for collar
Final a doubt for you. Yeah, okay, [you] do. Whatever you think is [best]. I'm gonna go see what's going on in this
Here thing or I guess that's not where I go for it, but I don't know how you could have watched anyone oh
Here in the armory [ooh]
Alrighty then eight seven one four
all righty then
And this is where I just saw okay [alright]. I'll take what I can get let's do this
I'll take that and that and THAT
We got a shotgun. I'll take that well I got the inventory space
I can always go back and dump this stuff break it down in materials
Which is what I need these are the materials that I need?
whoa
All right, so I got a bunch of stuff
I want to run back to the I'm gonna run back to the processing plant. I'll be right
I've got a spare one of these drums that don't that all right. That [should] be good
All right crank it crank yank. It. Give me some good stuff. Give me more neuromods, baby
Shibidydibidy
Ahh, [that's] exactly what I needed a ton of mineral material because I think that is the one thing oh yeah
It is can I get more neuromods baby
Please yes, please
Yes, please. Yes, please. [oh], yes, please
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. [oh], thank [you]. Thank [you] very much
Okay, so I got that let me just carry on here, huh?
Hello
[I'll] get it
But when do you think will gets that for [each]? [I] [mattered] out there as we speak?
What do you think happened? Are you saying tell her my eyes on it
Could be some micrometeoroids punched a hole rare, but it happens
Okay, good. Hopefully it's just that yeah, hopefully is there something. You're not telling me
No, of course not. It's just that storage room has classified exotic materials
We really can't have it be inaccessible. I
understand
Okay, all right. I want to get in there, too
[I] just [don't] know what I'm gonna be able to do that and get away from the vision
That's all for warping in my mind and with this [Eu] Christine
I'm sorry about that, but either way [I'm] all out of time for this episode
so thank you everybody so much for watching don't know why everything's going crazy here, but
[uh] is so thanks again everybody for watching and as always I will [see] you in the next video
[oh]